E aí
[Música]
É o Poder do Agora eu tenho dito que o
futuro que todos buscam está relacionada
exatamente no que nós estamos fazendo
hoje no nosso presente pois bem Eu
gostaria de perguntar para vocês se
vocês estudaram para aprender a montar
negócios a vender não Nós estudamos para
aprender um ofício uma profissão os
negócios e as vendas nós começamos a
estudar tem pouco mais de 40 anos e tem
quatro mil anos que nós abrimos os
nossos negócios espera amanhã Esperamos
o nosso cliente chegar e de repente de
um momento para o outro
e esse cliente não entra mais mudou tudo
logo na vez de vocês
é mas muitos imaginam que mudou por
causa da pandemia Não meu nome é Fred
Rocha eu sou um apaixonado pelo
consumidor pelas culturas e pelos povos
mas desconsiderando a pandemia as coisas
já tinham mudado
e talvez a gente não tivesse parado para
prestar atenção porque às vezes as
revoluções elas são longas duram de 20 a
30 anos e eu pergunto quem é que é
vendedor
Há muitos não se consideram vendedor e
eu brinco que um médico se ele não for
um vendedor
e ele só vai curar com a galere gripe
todos nós para sermos bem sucedidos nós
temos que vender
a venda para mim nada mais é do que uma
relação humana se preocupe com problema
das pessoas que elas naturalmente vão se
preocupar com vocês
Oi bom dia eu ouvi essa frase de uma
grande pensadora do varejo talvez muito
de vocês conhece não dá mais para
brincar de vendinha da Uber trudys você
já ouviram falar dessa prestadora essa
grande pensadora do varejo é minha mãe a
dona tudinha a minha mãe resolveu fechar
o seu negócio e disse meu filho meu
cliente não vem mais aqui como antes e
Se eu não sair da loja e em busca deles
e eu não conseguirei seguir como é o
negócio hoje aos 71 anos ela acaba não
de me ligar um pouco antes do Ted para
perguntar se a maquininha dela tinha
link para mandar para uma cliente porque
a cliente estava sem cartão no momento e
ela é alguma cidade do interior de Minas
aos 71 anos está vendendo
bom e foi através desse start da dona
todinha
e eu resolvi parar de vender do jeito
velho
e quando eu digo parar de vender do
jeito velho eu digo para vocês que tem
quatro mil anos que nós abrimos os
nossos negócios pela manhã
nós esperamos o cliente entrar
e eu comecei a ficar curioso para saber
se sempre foi assim e foi graças a minha
mãe que aos 36 anos até então não
conhecia nenhum país do mundo eu comecei
a viajar
Oi e aí essa foi a primeira vez que eu
fui os Estados Unidos com a mochila nas
costas apenas depois de vender o
computador da agência o último eu falei
eu vou porque se eu não sair para o
mundo para estudar o que tá acontecendo
e eu nunca vou ser que eu pretendo você
e dos Estados Unidos eu cortei América
toda de carro depois cortei o Brasil de
Kombi depois Cortei a Europa de
motorhome depois Cortei a China até
mesmo caminhando
o Ron Kong
em Jerusalém eu cortei o Oriente Médio
de carro foi para Jordânia no Cairo
Visitei todos os mercados seja esse
grande mercado no Cairo ou seja
maravilhosa Times Square
e o mundo todo tinha mudado as
habilidades que trouxeram os negócios
até aqui não serão as mesmas habilidades
o que nós teremos com os nossos negócios
agora para frente e não é por causa da
academia
e na verdade nós temos desafios
culturais que já existiam e nós não
dávamos atenção
e até então
e nós temos três desafios preço
independência do Consumidor intangíveis
e vem nos impossibilitando
e os donos de negócios a grande mudança
digital primeiro que nós ainda
acreditamos que ainda é a maior
percepção de valor de um produto não é
o vendedor de rede que me desculpe
é mas logo logo você não pendurar uma
rede para o cliente balançar Não adianta
só começar a vender numa rede por 300
entregar duas por 30 até porque o
cliente Três anos depois baixar essas
redes tendo uma gaveta mofadas porque
não era aquilo que ele precisava
é um dos pontos mais importantes da
mudança de postura de consumo É que
nesses últimos 4000 anos os consumidores
sempre dependeram do Comércio e quando
eu falo depender do Comércio isso é tão
poderoso que todas as cidades do planeta
só nasceram por causa da migração dos
consumidores em busca de qualidade de
vida e qualidade de vida era morar perto
onde tinha tratamento de dente médico
emprego perto do Comércio perto do
serviço perto dos mercados
o e todas as cidades do planeta se
replicaram porque as pessoas entende o
que tinham que mudar de um lugar para
outro em busca de qualidade de vida e
agora qualidade de vida não tá mais
relacionado a morar perto do Comércio é
para na sua cidade todos os todos da
classe média que antes moravam no centro
da cidade estão em condomínios longe da
cidade ou em sítios O que é qualidade de
vida não está mais relacionado amor
aonde a morar perto de onde se compra
coisas
E com isso
é aquele cliente que a gente achou que
tinha sumido da loja na verdade continua
comprando mas não com a dependência que
ele tinha antes
eu e o dono do negócio preciso entender
essa mudança é outra característica
importante é que até então nós de
terminar vamos o sucesso de um negócio
através dos seus bens tangíveis prédios
filiais stoq carros
só isso nada mais funciona para o
consumidor
o tipo São Thomé que na imagem toca na
chácara de Cristo para poder acreditar
hoje não é mais
é ver para crer é crer para ver entender
que esses negócios antigos como era
antes não funcionam mais e para se
montar um negócio para o futuro eu
convido vocês
o anão mais criarem uma empresa para
ganhar dinheiro mas empresa veio para
dar lucro para ganhar dinheiro não
espero
o seu negócio Não venha por causa do
dinheiro venha para ajudar as pessoas
crie uma empresa para ajudar as pessoas
dinheiro é consequência não é a
finalidade do negócio e Isso se chama
propósito a primeira primeiro degrau da
escada que nós vamos conviver até hoje
nesses caríssimos e poucos minutos de um
Ted o propósito está relacionado ajudar
a algo alguém além de você mesmo através
do seu negócio e eu te deixo uma
pergunta para você refletir onde ou como
seu produto
é um serviço ajuda na vida das pessoas e
para isso eu tenho uma frase mágica que
mudou diretamente a minha vida e pode
ajudá-lo a construir seu propósito
e a gente só ganha dinheiro resolvendo o
problema dos outros
É parece simples mas é complexo tem um
negócio com propósito porque porque tem
quatro mil anos que a gente faz da mesma
forma e tudo o que é cultural é complexo
não existe tempo de mudança
e no propósito vamos para as pessoas
todo mundo sabe que tem que investir em
pessoas mas investir para que Fred o que
as pessoas minha gente São os fios
Condutores para que o nosso propósito
chega até o nosso cliente a pessoas
viram para mim frente eu preciso engajar
a minha equipe o meu time Mas como você
vai engajar
e as pessoas se você não tem um
propósito para ser um negócio você só
pensa em dinheiro pessoas não se engajam
em dinheiro pessoas se engajem no
propósito
e me ajudar as pessoas as pessoas se
perguntam quando vão trabalhar todos os
dias de manhã para que que serve o que
eu estou fazendo não é sobre o emprego
a propósito pessoas como fio com fios
Condutores EA inovação palavra tão
falada em que todas as empresas querem
Inovar todo o tempo mas não consegue não
consegue por quê
é porque não tem propósito inovação
trabalha como um facilitador para que o
seu propósito chega até seu cliente
é uma história rápida da Dona Maria uma
dona de uma pousada
Oi bom dia acordou e falou Fred eu quero
Inovar no meu negócio agora tem um
propósito falei Dona Maria Qual que é o
propósito da sua Pousada ela Fred é
fazer com que os meus hóspedes se sintam
em casa ali Nossa a partir daí talvez
você consiga Inovar Dona Maria é frete
como
e lá em casa eu tomo café hora que eu
quiser
o porquê que seu café da manhã não possa
ser de 6 a meio-dia ela quer você tá
doido é só próximo vai fazer com que as
pessoas se sintam em casa
ou então na casa da gente a gente toma
na hora que quiser e naquele minuto a
Dona Maria mudou o café da manhã dela de
6 horas meio-dia
e renovou
e para que o seu propósito
e se realizasse uma força maior
e as pequenas inovações não estão
relacionados à tecnologia São
relacionados às pessoas assim como a
tecnologia
o motor intangível
É mas não precisamos para vender todo
mundo acha que tecnologia é para vender
não tecnologia para vender mais e melhor
e a tecnologia serve para levar o Nosso
propósito para mais pessoas
e a tecnologia serve para facilitar com
que o nosso propósito se realize
e onde outros a tecnologia botão
software na empresa para facilitar a
vida da empresa e atrapalhar a vida do
cliente
a tecnologia é para facilitar escalar
negócios
é facilitar para o cliente facilitar
para que o seu propósito se desenvolva
É nesse escada onde nós só temos valores
intangíveis propósito cuidar de pessoas
inovação tecnologia nós chegamos a
comunicação
e Eu me formei em publicidade e
propaganda na universidade de Ribeirão
Preto em 2000 AVT 20 anos atrás
Um item muito pouco tempo eu aprendi a
me comunicar de verdade
a comunicação não é preço produto como
todos os negócios do mundo tem o feito
a comunicação
não é para contar para as pessoas como
você pode ajudar seu cliente
e a comunicação é para você falar para
as pessoas como você pode contribuir com
elas comunicação não é para você ficar
falando eu tenho melhor atendimento eu
sou maior nisso
eu não tenho o melhor daquilo eu tenho
mais lojas eu só isso só aquilo dane-se
quem você é
eu quero saber o que você faz pelas
pessoas
é utilize a comunicação para isso e
nessa escada nós estamos de escada do
repreender
em qualquer pessoa qualquer negócio pode
re empreender de novo a sua empresa
seguindo valores totalmente intangíveis
o que não precisar de um real para
investir
é um propósito Poderoso com pessoas
engajadas com a Inovação para facilitar
com a tecnologia para escalar com a
comunicação para contar para as pessoas
o que você pode fazer com ela você
conquista clientes mas Fred o que que o
cliente está fazendo
é uma escada de intangíveis o cliente eu
pego aí na loja não pega mais assim como
você que está me assistindo não tá aqui
nesse palco
tu não tá no meu auditório
e o cliente ficou em tangível aquele
cliente que sumiu da loja não se pega
mais ele virou um Fantasminha
o like a gente gente a clientes
e para você empreender a sua empresa
se você precisa
e não combustível de energia
é uma energia para subir essa escada não
é café
o café aquele que movimentou uma
revolução industrial
Oi hoje para movimentar essa nova
evolução que vivemos
e nós precisamos do mais poderoso de
todos os intangíveis
e do conhecimento
e o conhecimento energia que precisamos
É para subir a escada
e o conhecimento transforma as pessoas
E aí
e as pessoas conduzem propósitos
a propósito dos transformam negócios
o que sem eles
e não existe movimento no planeta
e o trabalho energia mais poderosa do
ser humano porque é o momento que nós
podemos usar toda a nossa força
e a contribuir com outras pessoas
e não invés de ganhar um abraço como o
pagamento
e nós ganhamos dinheiro mas são trocas
esse dinheiro nada mais é do que a
representação do trabalho do outro
Oi gente dinheiro a representação do
nosso trabalho
a propósito transforma o negócios
é independente se esse negócio é real
digital o virtual negócios são negócios
pessoas são pessoas
Oi e aí eu lembro vocês a frase mágica
e a gente só ganha dinheiro
o resolvendo o problema dos outros
a Travessa frase você constrói um
propósito poderoso
é um até através de uma frase mais
mágica do que essa
e a gente ganha mais dinheiro
e resolvendo os problemas
o que as pessoas não saibam que tem
e lembre-se vendas é uma relação humana
e como toda relação exige reciprocidade
empatia e paixão se preocupe com
problema das pessoas que elas
naturalmente vão se preocupar com vocês
Muito obrigado Fred Rocha
o gol valeu